[Musique]
moi dans les morceaux maintenant
et en colère c'est ainsi que l'actrice
iranienne Fatma
a apporté son soutien aux manifestants
violemment réprimandés par les forces de
l'ordre
elle n'est pas la seule le comédien
iranien Mohamed Amrani a aussi pris
position
nous le sommes aussi avec le sang encore
chaud nos martyrs ironise-t-il dans une
vidéo diffusée sur le réseau Tik Tok oui
la révolution est féministe et surtout
avec ces jeunes écolières où elle a
commencé mais elle devient aussi une
révolution
épaulée par des jeunes hommes
[Musique]
des jeunes qui s'en prennent désormais
au symbole du pouvoir
anaïshapeau au nord-est du pays la
statue à la gloire de l'ayatollahomeini
et décapité mais aussi et on compte le
poids on voit que la machine est précise
du régime des moulins aussi s'intensifie
et devient de plus en plus brutal
dans cette vidéo une femme est frappée
par des policiers anti-émeutes parmi eux
des femmes elle est embarquée dans un
fourgon lasséné diffusé par un médiocal
elle se passe à ta brise on sait que
même si le régime est extrêmement menacé
il a des capacités répressives
importantes c'est une révolte dans la
mesure où le régime n'est pas changé que
le régime n'est pas abattu mais le
reptile peut avoir peur parce que c'est
une révolte qui prend une ampleur de
plus en plus grande un régime qui répète
cette fois-ci par la voix de son
président Ibrahim raïti que des forces
étrangères tentent de déstabiliser le
pays
le président américain répond que les
iraniennes ont le droit de porter ce que
bon leur semble l'accusation que ceux
qui protestent servent l'étranger est
une visation rituelle dans tous les
pouvoirs qui sont contestés évidemment
cette jeunesse qui se révolte n'est en
rien animée par les États-Unis Israël
mais par leur soif de liberté
un mois de manifestation qui ne
s'essouffle pas armée de leur
détermination les jeunes continuent de
descendre dans la rue au moins 23
mineurs auraient été tués selon
amnestyle errant ici à Radio-Canada
Montréal